The Joe Rogan Experience you got
babysitted by Sam Tennyson it's one of
the funniest [__] stories of all time
like what a crazy thing your mom did it
was she left you as a little child as
one of the most maniacal comedians
that's ever existed well it wasn't it
wasn't exactly like that it was more it
was more like Sam was I was 14 years old
I was a shorter to cook at the comedy
Center in Westwood my mom would put Sam
on last because all he would do is
Scream and then he would literally you
know there'd be six people left in the
room in Westwood and he'd throw the
stools he'd throw his stool at the
audience members they'd Scamper off he'd
smoke weed in the parking lot and then
he would
um you know I'd feed him hamburgers so I
kind of just I was always taking care of
comedians what year was this this was uh
probably 84 80 84.85 I was in high
school he hit in 86. yes and he really
hit yeah yeah so did never tell you my
story how I found out about him
it's probably Boston with parento or
something no a girl that I worked with
at the Boston Athletic Club um
still this day I can't remember her
[__] name she was really cool though
she was this big volleyball player girl
like big athletic girl and uh she goes
to me she goes have you seen Sam Kinison
Sam Kennison whatever his name was
um I go no I have it and so she acts out
in the parking lot the whole bit about
him
no no no the the uh homosexual
homosexual necrophiliacs oh God yeah
yeah yeah she acted it out in the
parking lot she's like oh oh life keeps
[__] in the ass even after you're
dead it never ends me laughing at her
acting it out in the parking lot made me
go get the VHS tape so I got a VHS tape
of his his HBO special and I was like
holy [__] so I found out about it from a
girl acting out the bit she saw on her
stomach in the parking lot going oh oh
feels like something's in my ass you
can't believe it that angle was genius
it's such a [__] hilarious genius
point of view you that that night was
that was 1987 and that was at the Roxy
on Sunset and my mom had an after party
for him at the house wow at the Doheny
house so that night afterwards Sam came
to the house with everyone and um and I
was so excited because I wanted to show
my my saltwater fish tank because as a
kid I had a saltwater fish tank and I
brought him up to my room and I said Sam
look at my tank and he wasn't impressed
at all he's like but he told me to take
the top off the saltwater fish tank it
was a big black top and I took it down
he dumped all this coke on it
and he started chopping up lines and he
says have fun and me and my friend Dave
we snorted Sam's Coke that night oh my
God and I felt like so cool
I felt like no for real I was like of
course [__] this guy you know and then I
just followed him around so as far as
him him babysitting me it was it was no
that was just the way it would described
yeah I mean Lois Bromfield babysitting
me Jackson Perdue babysat me so you were
my binder Argus Hamilton all those guys
yeah so you were essentially just like
his young Protege yeah I would fall it
was like the Michael Jordan commercial
like you know the kid want to be like
Mike I want to be like or I want to be
like Sam right so look at you yeah so
what year is that I was probably 11. wow
it was probably 11. what a [__] crazy
place to grow up yeah back then oh my
God back then back I mean yeah I mean
there's so many stories dude I mean I'm
there now and it's it's great obviously
it's the store but when Mom was there it
was just like you never know what the
[__] was gonna happen you never knew it
was gonna pull in the [__] lot right
you never knew who was gonna come up it
was just like yeah it was like it was
like someone shooting guns yeah not
literally but just as far as the energy
boom boom boom I mean Eddie Murphy used
to show up with like six rolls royces
like for real dude and then Richard
would show up and you know and all these
guys would just roll this is this is
around when you got there it was kind of
towards right you got there 94 94. yeah
I saw that four when I got there yeah I
saw the um the calendar you had for my
mom where she put your name I thought
that was really cool yeah it was very
cool yeah so um yeah so that was
that was that time you know you know I'm
really proud of this artist look at this
right here I guess yeah what is that
what year is that
that was last year yeah Pauly Shore
bringing up Eddie Murphy yeah when did
Eddie retire so he retired in what year
he stopped doing stand-up when
um I don't know so while I was that I
was at his house probably five years ago
and I was just like dude what are you
doing like you're [__] you're the
best dude like let's go your mother had
amazing taste the funniest was this is
I'd sit next to her as well and I would
see people
to go on stage and if she called you
over you did good and she didn't call
you or she wasn't interested you know I
just they do their set and they just
walk by and they're like looking at her
and she's just like
it's going through her papers and [__]
yeah but yeah but she liked you you know
she she brought you in you know but
having something like that like some
gold standard bear Keeper at the top was
very valuable for the comedians it was
very valuable and she also would do when
she thought you were funny she'd put you
on after Killers you always had to
follow like whoever was famous that was
gonna go down there she wanted to make
sure that you were tested
throw you into the fire and that's how
you get better she just [__] new man
she knew and it's all things that people
talk about now but I think in in her own
way she sort of devised uh like a modern
strategy for getting better at stand up
having the environment which she created
having one person who's like ruthlessly
critical that watches over everybody's
material and everybody sets and then
everybody aspires for the approval of
your mom and she had had it set up so
perfectly and because she wasn't a comic
either and because she was you know
she's royalty in the stand-up comedy
world she had everyone's respect so
there and and she was right she was
right she she knew she knew what the
[__] she did she didn't like Seinfeld
which was hilarious which is hilarious
he he lived up the street from me and my
mom
so me and my mom would walk the dog
Kelly her dog and we would walk by his
house you know what I mean oh there he
is not happening
you know rat tat tat New York keep it
keep it going let's keep moving I'm like
Mom be nice to him he's going no let's
go and she just didn't buy into it
that's so funny you know what I mean she
didn't buy and do it I wonder why
maybe because he didn't need her I don't
know because he had already made it he
had a sitcom he was Seinfeld oh so he
was already on Seinfeld when he was a he
I mean he'd been on that show for a
while it was around that time and was
the early 90s right yeah I don't know
what the exact date was
or Seinfeld she didn't like it when you
were too developed correct yeah she
liked getting people that had talent
that were on the up and she didn't
really like a lot of New York comics
for some reason she understood you know
there was also a rift between obviously
her and Bud Friedman and her and Lauren
Michaels people ask me like hey when
you're doing all your movies did you
ever do Saturday Night Live do you ever
host Saturday Night Live and I never did
and I think a lot of it has to do with
Lauren Michaels and my mom I'm sure it
can't help no can't help because she was
harsh you know what I mean my mom had
Jim Carrey and Damon Wayans and all
these guys and they were from the store
yeah and um you know so uh uh I wonder
if your mom was concerned that if
someone like Seinfeld got on that people
who would want to see sitcom style stand
up like very sterile stand up would
start coming to the clubs
like and then you would start getting
people going to see people just because
they're famous and not really because
they're good
I mean she probably had a method to her
approach I wonder what she was thinking
or I wonder if she just didn't want it
because he was already developed and she
couldn't work with him I don't think she
just liked him I just don't think that
she just don't think she liked that
style but as she's driving by his house
she's still talking no we're walking
yeah walking by the house and then he
says he sits and that's another thing he
never asked me on his [__] car show I
got all my friends on his car show I'm
like dude and it's again I think like
it's always awkward and Leno too
whenever I see Leno it's [__] weird
yeah Letterman's cool I love Letterman
but llano's always been weird because
these guys like Leno striked against my
mom and there was this weird thing and
and you know and and and my relationship
with Lena was very different he's always
been very nice to me and we both love
cars so I have great conversations with
him about cars I don't know the history
of that I mean I do know it but I wasn't
aware of it but but my point is is that
he never did anything to me I'm just
talking about my mom's relationship with
Jay and I think it has to do with the
strike but when I did see Jay at the
Palm restaurant in Beverly Hills years
ago when my mom was there he came up and
gave her a kiss but then of course she
mumbled yeah the [__] is going on with
him get the [__] out
that's just the way she was so funny
dude